people often confuse food allergies and
food intolerances but it's important to
know the difference because they each
require a different treatment so what is
the difference
a food allergy is your body's immune
system responding to specific proteins
in certain foods for instance in
shellfish one of the triggers for
allergic reactions is a protein called
tropomyosin and with peanuts it can be a
reaction to one of its many proteins
when a food particle enters the body of
someone who's allergic the body's immune
system perceives it as a problem an
invader just as your body might respond
to a virus is a threat with food
allergies part of your immune system
sees the protein of the food as a threat
the allergic reaction can be thought of
as a disproportionate and inappropriate
response from the immune system to the
food allergic reactions can range from
being mild tingles in the mouth hives
and rashes to being extremely severe
like having trouble breathing and they
can even be life-threatening allergic
reactions with some exceptions almost
always happen quickly within 30 minutes
of eating or exposure to the food
of food intolerance on the other hand is
usually our body having trouble
digesting certain foods unlike allergies
food intolerances are not related to the
immune system for instance being lactose
intolerant means you don't have enough
of the enzyme that breaks down the
lactose in dairy intolerance to certain
foods can often result in digestive
issues including bloating diarrhea or
just generally feeling unwell
intolerance to food can happen pretty
quickly too but could also show up in
the next few days in other words If you
experience unpleasantness from something
you've eaten a day before most of the
time it's not an allergy there's a third
kind of reaction that's neither an
allergy or an intolerance for example
celiac disease is an autoimmune
condition triggered by eating foods
containing gluten celiac disease may
share some similar symptoms to food
intolerance such as bloating or belly
pain but unlike celiac disease food
intolerances don't damage the small
intestine so with all these real but
nuanced differences what's the best way
to get a proper diagnosis
don't get one of those do-it-yourself at
home food sensitivity kits those tests
are not scientifically proven to do what
they purport to do and they they aren't
reliable diagnostic tools if you wonder
whether you have an allergy or an
intolerance or celiac disease talk to
your doctor they'll be able to recommend
the right course of action and in the
case of food allergies an allergist is
your go-to person the two common ways
they'll be able to diagnose you is by
taking a really good food history and
giving you an oral food challenge by
giving you certain foods and seeing what
happens in a medically safe and
controlled environment an allergist can
also come up with a plan in case you're
exposed to a food you're allergic to and
may even be able to recommend treatments
for some of those allergies